nos petits comiques soyez les bienvenus
en retenue spencer bettany fridge marta
vous avez tous très bien ce qui vous
amène vous devriez vous demandez qui
vous êtes qui vous voulez devenir fort
heureusement vous allez avoir tout le
temps d'y réfléchir
en rangeant le sous sol ça ça craint
lorsqu'on sort c'est quoi jumanji un jeu
pour tous ceux qui espèrent laissé
derrière eux leur univers
qu'est ce que c'est des noms d' avatar
temps choisi est incarnera le père ce
qui correspond lequel je prends ça doit
pas être importants anjou pasqua la
caisse que thomas quaas mêlée
[Musique]
oh la vache
pourquoi je sais que tu es free jazz
ouais j'suis frites tu t'es qui toi
c'est moi à spencer
est elle là qui sait martin je crois
qu'on a a été aspirée dans le jeu et
qu'on est devenus les personnages qu'on
a choisi autrement dit je suis et annie
[Musique]
oh
bethany béthanie
[Applaudissements]
non je devenu namur est obèse
bienvenue dans du monde j
seulement des cas mais pourquoi je suis
aussi là les gars
moi je
m
je dois vous dire une chose je crois que
j'ai vraiment beaucoup de punch
hu il est trop fort
un homme est un vrai challenge partial
pas j'aime pas ça va allez arrête arrête
je le kiffe trop